Hey Youtubers it's Charlie this is going to
be my arrow episode 2 video we got to meet
Lonnie Machin and Anarky all explained that
they changed him from the comics just a little
bit so explain as we move through this salsa
gone real quick reminder to I'm doing a reverse
flash ring giveaway again this week all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video so let's get
going, number five meet Mr. Terrific so the
introduction hears that Felicity is now officially
CEO of Palmer Tech but there bleeding money
she has the fire bunch of people and Curtis
Holt here Mr. Terrific comes up with a plan
but because Felicity is Felicity she does
one have to fire all these people so they
say that they're going to come up with this
genius Technology to save the company I feel
like it's pretty reasonable that were all
in agreement that it has something to do with
the T Spheres like that the solution the text
solution is gonna save the company will have
something to do with Mr. Terrific's Technology
is said that it's not due for a while so don't
expect those to be a thing for a couple more
episodes of the really fun IRL Easter egg
here is that is Emily Bett is like calling
people into the office to fire them this person
here is actually her real life best friend
I think it's a roommate to so she is firing
her own real-life roommate it just funny that
Emily Bett gets to fire her best friend but
he wanted to come be on my show all fire you
that was actually kind of the theme this episode
is like a tale of two firings people would
take it vastly different like Felicity's person
that she fire seer takes it pretty well however
Anarky on the other side of things doesn't
take it too well when he gets fired by Jamie
a darken hive step in my office you're fired
on a number for me arrow's version of Anarky
Lonnie Machin and there been at least four
different versions of Anarky in the comics
there is doing is using the name of the very
first Anarky Lonnie Machin and encounter doing
their own thing with the character the two
most recent versions of the character debuted
during the new 52 the direction two separate
versions of Anarky one was an African-American
just like in a normal person in the other
was a corrupt politician so obviously arrow
is is kind of doing its own thing I have seen
a lot of people complain about Mr. Terrific
in Anarky in the comics just like them being
really great characters that have kinda been
mishandled to use it with arrow does is is
they'll take big characters in the comics
that they they feel haven't really been done
justice in those do their own version Malcolm
Merlyn is the best example that relatively
important character in the comics but is hasn't
really gotten an awesome comic book run yet
so I'm totally cool with arrow doing its own
version of Mr. Terrific and Anarky now Anarky
storyline as you can see is something of an
origin like this episode just puts them on
the comic book path to wearing a mask they
did say before the season started the part
of the fun of the character is is that Thea
as well as Damien Darhk are going to be partially
responsible for who he becomes so even though
he was already kinda speechifying his Anarky
philosophy in this episode he is going to
fully take the Anarky persona by the end of
the season they were kind of subtle about
it but you can kind see this parallel between
the his character just going nuts going off
the deep end in Anarky doing the same thing
will have to watch those two characters are
asked to see how they mirror each other during
the season usually when you like when you
look at like a member of team arrow for any
given storyline her arc that they have there
is someone else or a villain character that
also has a similar type of art which actually
kinda leads nicely to my number three vote
Queen for mayor so right out of the comic
books Oliver Queen get to be running for mayor
doesn't necessarily mean he's going to win
the mayor ship but he's definitely going to
be running for it so his May oral arc this
season is going to be mirrored by Danforth's
character both heroic characters that will
have their own ideas about how to fix star
city 90 there's probably some questions about
Danforth's motives like we we don't know a
lot about her yet we just know that she is
an old family friend we don't know she has
ties to Damien darker any that the hive elements
in the city but don't be surprised if she
has like some twists and turns in her character
if she is no more rough for a long time that
she probably also knows Merlyn maybe she was
part of the undertaking a long time ago we
know will find out Jeri Ryan gonna be a ton
of fun the season I'm so happy that she's
on the show is going to assimilate all of
your hearts is gonna be so much fun and actually
speaking of assimilation just to make you
more Star Trek references Oliver assimilates
in the flashbacks with Berendt blitzkrieg
so this character here is Berendt blitzkrieg
from the comics what they're doing is is there
just using the name he's not can be anything
like the character from the comics he just
gonna be the big villain of the flashbacks
of the season-long he's going to be the most
evil person on the island and it looks like
Oliver's drink the Kool-Aid they flat-out
killed the flashback way which I feel was
an awesome move the way it was just one of
the weirdest things about the flashbacks Stephen
Amell used to make the joke that it's actually
a Jared paddle like you way just because their
friends in real life and in Jared has like
that really long hair I think I mentioned
in my Q&A video but amongst other things mysticism
is going to be a big theme of the flashbacks
soak in episode one where Oliver's like I've
seen some things man it's mysticism he's talking
about his time on the island that these flashbacks
the season so what's happening on the island
is going to give them some insight into the
mysticism of Damien dark in his powers the
course of my number one WTF moment fee and
Laurel go on a field trip to Nanda Parbat
with a quick stop by Sara's grave give me
all of your dead person diet jokes you need
to get some more son Katie lots you look like
a corpse so it wasn't clear from like a lot
of the interaction between Thea and Laurel
and all of her Laurel had no idea what happened
with the Lazarus bid she does know how it
works is even know it exists so poor she gets
the idea in her head that they may be we can
do something with Sarah maybe we can say for
using this Mistry hot tub that Thea keeps
talking about in behind-the-scenes like that
the production that's actually what they call
it they caught their hot tub said now we get
to go see Merlyn in this that we get to find
out about how this is going to be fighting
Merlyn for control of the league that storyline
I don't know how big the storyline is going
to be the season because I think that John
Barrowman is still a series regular but Nyssa
is not so they might not be around quite as
much as they were last season in the way we
already know that Sears can be resurrected
but it's gonna require the help of Constantine
and all of her that episodes not gonna happen
for a couple more weeks select the next couple
weeks will just be explain the mechanics of
the Lazarus pit why it won't work beyond a
certain point but for those of you that are
asking to the longest time.
That the Lazarus pit is still effective for
like the longest you can be dead is a year
that's the furthest out they've ever done
in the comics and the longer you've been dead
the more serious the consequences that the
longer you go insane so if you're been dead
a year and you get resurrected you will go
ape shed so let me know in the comments though
like what was your favorite part about this
episode was a seeing Anarky get his origin
story is in seeing Sarah's dead body I'm actually
really happy that they didn't make her look
super beautiful she's been in the ground for
more than a year of course she's gonna look
really desiccated for those either asking
to the reason her grave says 2007 is because
that's what her grave originally said they
first thought that she died when the boat
crashed and she came back she was still alive
these things they never change the grave there
was never a body that was buried originally
it was always an empty casket so when she
actually died last season they just put her
body in the casket that was already in the
ground and the only other Easter eggs that
I haven't mentioned are the dig at the green
arrow name like Cisco on the flash last week
said I hate it when they put a color in the
name Quentin also kinda made fun of them putting
green in the name and then all of her brought
the Fern back so like the fern lives on in
the season for severe big Felicity Schipper
or he just liked all the firm jokes from season
three it has continued on into season for
who knows how long it'll survive probably
as long as the show goes on actually I think
the only other weird thing that I wanted to
add a note was Damien dark's policy on kidnapping
for he told Anarky you cross the line it seems
a little strange that a villain so big we
get so crazy over something like that Sears
can let me know do you think this throws any
gasoline on the fire that is the theory that
Damien dark is Felicity's father a human of
that's not true maybe Damien dark has a daughter
out there somewhere in the world that he's
father that the he also feels very protective
of regardless of his own villainous philosophy
oh and actually really cool if you guys in
here in my flash video Damien dark will cross
over to the flash season to just like the
heroes of crossover I don't know which episode
is going to be this can be the Flarrow episode
or something else but it's gonna be a lot
of fun so it can happen next is I still have
The Walking Dead Q&A but I'm in a do a flashier
Q&A for this from the end of the reverse flash
ring giveaway winner hopefully that will be
out tomorrow at least by Friday so while you
guys wait for that click here for my flash
episode 2 video from last night and you can
click here to catch up with an Agents of SHIELD
from last night to thank you so much watching
everybody high five and I'll see you tomorrow!